this is a very strong torment including
a mix of young Thailand as well as
experience what are your expectations
about this tournament right the
tournaments get stronger younger players
are almost dominating and
um overall my expectations are first of
all to play well and to
be out to my own standard and of course
if I can get top three that would be
amazing too play well
and scores importance I guess and that
was a game that's the goal and I've been
playing an instrument for many years and
I've had a lot of heartbreaks so at some
point I do want to claim the title I
just want to like play to the best of my
ability
um I'm not like putting a lot of
pressure on myself because this is my
first time playing and I perform better
like without pressure so it is kind of
weird because last time I was here I won
so I feel like any other like result
other than that would kind of be like
disappointing because it's like that's
that was a standard
um so I feel like that is what I'm
aiming for
um it is also kind of like a tough
tournament for me right now to not just
chest wise but also because you know I'm
in school so I'm really trying to
balance everything as well like this is
the first time playing a department like
this in college
um so I'm just trying to you know do my
best
um like still maintain like my
schoolwork and you know just have like a
good time I don't come in this year with
big expectations uh it's great to see
some of the youngsters haven't done so
well in the past few years and having
progressed so much so I I feel
just excited to play again and really I
think just the first year that I really
don't have any expectations I just want
to play good chess it's not easy time
like politically and I'm originally from
Ukraine and last like months I was busy
with other things
and uh I I'm trying to like recall how
good I was when I played when I won U.S
championships last years and I will try
to just repeat my results
like from past and I don't have like big
expectations and it's not easy to answer
question to answer oh I think my
expectations are still the same as
they've always been you know to try to
do my best and if that works out
hopefully I can win my ninth title
um and yeah I still feel pretty good I
feel like I'm still in pretty good shape
despite getting uh you know older in
years
um well I just want to do my best since
my first year and like a lot of people I
have I have like watched and admired or
playing here so yeah it's a good
experience to um clay against them
players should definitely getting
stronger and this year we also have more
players than usual for team players it's
also getting younger I used to be one of
the younger ones not anymore my goal is
always to do my best and results will
just come so this is my first Year's
Women's Championship of course where my
expectations of course I want to try to
win foot with such a strong field it's
extremely hard for anybody so I think
more realistically I'd be happy with
like an even score especially since this
is like my first time playing it's
always great to get some experience I
just want to do my best as always in
every tournament
yeah I don't really have any super large
goals just try to play good chess
[Music]